if you were on an old episode of room  raiders what would you be most afraid  what would you be most afraid of being  found probably the drawer of sex toys  that i have because it's just  it's messy it also has like spray tan  cans in it and it's like and i was just  talking about this but like when you  don't  yeah just but you don't clean  your toys like right after which  sometimes you don't want to because  you're just like  tired and ashamed of what you've looked  at and you need to clear your cookies um  the stuff it dries and then the next  time you go to grab it um  it like like in the toy moves it like  flakes off like like snow like i always  think of christmas time it gets me in  the christmas spirit when i like go  through a drawer to look for something  and it's like ding ding and i always  hear jingle bells being played in my  head when i do that so i think it would  be yeah uh that a come crusted toy would  be the thing i wouldn't want them to  find overrated